[Music]
this week we've got idiot getaway cars
attacked and illegal camping
that's r2d2 saying it's weekend scramble
spawn on alright our first story I have
this hilarious ass video of this dude in
Virginia he's being chased by the police
and he tried to get away it's always a
bad like what do you think is gonna
happen where you going man do people not
know they have [ __ ] helicopters and
they got radios and communicate with
each other the ghetto bird they don't
know that's when I watch these films and
this like the car get away right but
there's never any helicopter in sight
you cannot escape a helicopter
yeah with Randy's a sheriff and it was
hilarious cuz like I was like how do you
catch her guys cuz he has the top
arrests in his department and he hates
walking and I was like if you don't walk
if you don't sprint how do you catch
you're like bad guys you know what he
said he says when he's in his black and
white if he can't find a parking space
because technically do not suppose was
parked in the red all the time if you
can't find a parking space that's within
at least three spaces of the place he
just parked him in the red just gonna
leave his [ __ ] lights on because I
don't give a [ __ ] but basically what
he's trying to arrest someone he says if
they start running he goes you just
gotta be smarter and set up perimeters
and then he's like if you know your city
really really well then you can just
figure it out where they're gonna run
they have no place to go and I'm like
yeah figure this would like be a
contract just the [ __ ] sticks goes
through their ankles and [ __ ] my
favorite [ __ ] is when guys slowed they
pull over and they go to a complete stop
right and then they wait for the cop to
stop and then they take that even fast
yeah right exactly their car that goes 0
to 60 in like 68 seconds I kind of
curious to see how many people have if
they've ever even escaped like a like a
Dirty Bird yeah it possible what's a
Dirty Bird
get over upside good girl I've got away
from cops on what I like have none of
you we're gonna we're gonna talk about
that you're a boy you're letting Dirty
Bird go different hoods I'll slap
different vernacular that's all there's
a sacramental thing 35 it's a sideways
cross I burn so I wonder if it's
actually possible because no matter how
fast you're going here it doesn't matter
just because of the disses and the
height you see everything it's like the
Eyewitness News are just like okay he's
just passing this light in that like
this the bird is enough to go anywhere
you see everything well I'm ready to see
a video yeah I'm ready to show you guys
the video this is so funny it's pretty
fast so check it out see what this one
1920s by the way whoa whoa how's that
even possible that's amazing go strided
the winds okay good
oh you probably had a stick shift you
didn't put the ebrake on so ceiling
neutral is just going forward I get it I
shouldn't ask [ __ ] didn't watch
enough kung fu movies or cop movies cuz
you're supposed to do this slide over
the hood buddy I just love that he's
like I have an idea and then turns into
that I have an idea but race my old car
now he was charged with driving while
intoxicated and possessing marijuana
okay well if he's drunk then I guess if
I was a cop that would actually make him
get away cuz I was like freeze and I see
that happen I would just are laughing
put my gun down
oh my [ __ ] god dude you guys gotta
[ __ ] see what just I just want to see
the clip after than the video after the
cops just like maybe go under the car or
did he just get hit
maybe he did try the slide he seemed
like he sorted right it tried that let's
see it he go he's on the curb that is a
man definitely that big a continue
there's some cops dying and they're just
laughing they taste them a little longer
but then they caught him eventually
wait wait wait he's got like he was on
the curb yeah that's pure adrenaline
Nigella's yeah am I crazy or did you
have a like a do she had on like a bad
hat yeah like one of those douchey hats
yeah those hats but kind of like
Gilligan I look at Gilligan hat Pharrell
that's Pharrell
I think it's Gilligan Island okay that's
awesome one more time I want to see if
the Hat stays on his head ghost ride the
whip he was goes right in the wind
remember remember that trend where
everyone's ghost riding the whip and
people were getting hit by their own
cars that's my favorite oh my god how
have we survived as a race I was so glad
everyone else was doing it so I don't
have to do it yeah everyone failed my
this is so funny I was jealous because I
just thought it was so [ __ ] funny I
like when it goes fried the whip and
they lose control the car and you see
all these people [ __ ] chasing the car
downhill and it hits something it's
funny I should start out in the Bay Area
Oh kind of just leaked everywhere man
yeah
I just loved all the [ __ ] where
everyone's dancing around the cars and
[ __ ] they're all getting into it and
then some guy would get hit by the car
and then some of the guys were like no
okay anyway we're playing the camera
when you're playing the camera all bets
what show must go on
well he looks like a UFC fighters yeah
yeah he looks famous they would hit
being like black panther or something
he's like a Wakanda warrior right there
because his face is really symmetrical
so we think he's famous
it's like structure like it's like a
it's a beautiful man what happened
there's not a controls car very well
sometimes it happens too right to the
best of us sometimes we don't want to be
right over
it happens you got ran over by your own
car no but Casey's car okay that's what
happened you got run over so his car
stick shift um we went to the movies it
was just us there's me tip from Casey so
then I get a text from one of them that
they're outside so I'm like oh cool so
then I run out and I guess he left his
car in neutral so as I'm like jumping
into the backseat the car like starts
rolling forwards we lived on like a
slight Hill and then my foot like I try
to get in my foots underneath the
freaking cool arch and then I'm like my
foot and then he just stops then the car
is completely on my foot that's good at
least he stopped at something yeah no
but I think the funniest part was cuz in
the middle of all that in the middle of
her foot getting run ran over and then
came stopping so it was like all this
like confusion like what what and I'm
like you're on her bucket and there was
that Goggin I feel like the car is on
her foot he was like huh I'm like stop
he's like tip the car is not on her foot
yeah that's ridiculous
could you do one of these scrunch up
your your your toes thing I couldn't it
was already too late like you can't move
on it it doesn't hurt though right no
cuz it's like I think the equal
distribution yeah it's so [ __ ] funny
cuz I think that happened were like Karl
go to the foot foots later you know and
then she took her foot up like it was a
cartoon the ring yeah it was like all
been hurt yeah but man who was flat with
tire marks i braised made sure okay
before I left I was laughing the whole
time it was my oh my god is your foot
okay yeah so that's probably what you
that guy survived alright for our next
story
the funny thing here that they're
talking about is the fact that
self-driving cars and all these like
self
robots like self-driving robots I guess
the you know the kind that they have on
the street that they're like delivering
food
those little dumbass things yeah like
the robots of itself robots when it's
common like their self robot robot
autonomous autonomous thank you
autonomous
vehicles yeah so anyway where humans are
the ones that are being angry at these
these robots to the point where they're
destroy humans ourself humans so solve
humans are getting ahead the self robots
but the robot and the humans are cool
it's not a robot I don't know miss self
robot so what does that make me cuz I
believed it well cuz she's reading the
news I could see why you believed her
liar you're the common man Joe you're
the voice for the people I get her train
of thought cuz just talking about self
parking self whatever will you remove
from the equation but then when she
wanted to speak generally she didn't
know how to remove so all I heard was
self robot and I could have moved past
that I was like why would any company
call it a self this weighs into what
I've been saying though which is that
people with robots will treat them
horribly yeah see I believe that so
who's but [ __ ] robots no I think
anyone not yet oh yeah yeah until you
can in Japan they probably argue I don't
even know robots hat but they will some
of them do they're just saying how it's
plenty of the fact that thing you know
that we're trying to make life easier
for humans but then in the end the
humans are still people there they're
making you I saw one of those little
shits and see IRA hate them I don't even
know why Santa Monica and it's just this
robot it's like the square thing that's
like delivering food that's time you
know why people are mad cuz you're like
you're taking my job it's just like this
little [ __ ] I'm like literally I could
pick this up and I'll have a meal why
are you why a little [ __ ] what's wrong I
don't know I just felt like like looking
at that thing I wanted to break it apart
and then steal from it what because it's
so easy no see I so there's a study done
couple years ago by a college where they
took a bunch of students and they're
like okay you're the slaves and you're
the slave masters and they had the
students all role-playing this ladies
and say masters and they had to halt the
study because the slave masters were
being too mean to this
who were the slave yeah I think they
really played into it I truly believe
that like with machines and [ __ ] like
people will just like do what you're
saying like just [ __ ] beat them up
and all kinds of [ __ ] because they're
they know that robots serve them that's
right
the same study happened but this time it
was um it was prison guards and then
prison I read about that
that was [ __ ] chaotic same-same out
there you go I think because there's no
consequence like people have like these
desires to do something really bad and
evil but because there's consequences
they won't do it but if there's in a
world without consequence it's like that
whole purge [ __ ]
you know that means they're gonna go
[ __ ] ham that's something like a
robot it's not a person so what the who
the [ __ ] cares you can take out all your
[ __ ] on it yeah which is great cuz like
you know like a lot of our dads used to
come home and take that [ __ ] on us right
yeah but having a robot to take it out
on is awesome yeah like that's good guys
you know what we just got to do is put
Ferrari logos on the robot and paint
them red and then make them really
really expensive so then if you do
something yeah cuz everyone's eye oh
[ __ ] to fry don't touch it I don't know
man those things get keyed I Drive up I
Drive a Mini Cooper
it's like it's like got a nice red color
to it and that got keyed like the first
week I had it it's a Mini Cooper I know
dude I'm just like damn it's a Mini
Coopers things like 20 G's I think we're
just prone to maybe you took someone's
parking space I'm a very polite partner
actually oh yeah thank you your car
sells so small you could actually pull
up and then someone else could come
behind it and you can share the parking
space it's true Holly I'm six four and a
half
interesting yeah that's right hey those
into ruins that man I love it I think
you're [ __ ] driving from the back
seat don't [ __ ] this no I'm dead
serious 100% so someone could sit in the
back no nobody can see no behind you and
someone's in the back behind you no
absolutely not
taking a two people seat will be me but
I don't need it I don't have a kid yet
and in a taller could fit so it's okay
right yeah I will say this Mini Coopers
though they go all the way [ __ ] back
if he's in your corner your Foxx
Carly W shut the [ __ ] yes what is your
girlfriend uh-huh she drives a orange
car BMW
not a BMW she drives a CMW where do
realize he's trying to make fun of me
what are you doing you would love the
incentive you'll be surprised how
spacious it is I'll be quiet w's are
small so then you don't slide around the
seats when you turn that's how they make
Dimps and if you use the coupon code
steve green our last story there's this
man living in australia where he's being
fined for living on his own property why
are you gonna do something like that is
he part of the [ __ ] HOH I is a
[ __ ] devil I agree so I get it that
was the biggest thing that kept me and
Nicky from getting a place for them
[ __ ] don't ever do it
what are they [ __ ] with you what are
they doing um so we don't do anything on
the outside because everything supposed
to look uniform that's fine but we have
our own home gym in our garage where you
can't see it when we train we do lift up
the gate the garage door so then the
rest of the people could see it we don't
ever have the music loud no we're pour
that into every and because we can't
Park both of our cars there we park them
on that you know on our driveway and
then we got a letter from HOA saying hey
you can't be doing that your cars need
to be parked in the garage because
that's what the garage is intended for
and I'm like what you're never Dickey
yeah I hate these people they're so
[ __ ] bored yeah when the whole
community no one's parking in the garage
like the modern the modern family uses
the garage as storage yes so you don't
like seeing y'all get fit
I know cuz it makes them go I need to
work out exactly so they might get your
teardown you're done that's what they're
saying but we're not gonna do [ __ ] you
know what it all fix the business of one
little Korean family that did talk some
little [ __ ] about you guys you got to
find out who those [ __ ] are it's
gonna be a we do have Korean neighbors
oh yeah
surfing I saw the surface but inside
there like kissed my Korean people hey
yeah we don't know I'm just saying but
Korean people are very
passive-aggressive so they're like oh
hello and they'll go inside a sheep
shake you [ __ ] Mexican Chinese a
piece of [ __ ] I'll just do that [ __ ] and
the baby I don't know where you are I'm
out of time I know I'll [ __ ] mix a
piece of [ __ ] yeah so this man his name
is rolling he bought this property in
Australia like this no one's messing
with my cable
brand-new shiny [ __ ] dish yeah his
trailers like garbage that's it
he thinks people were hey these people
are trying to steal his cable of course
doesn't know that that's not how it
works I got my bundle package in my
phone
nobody stealing my cable you can [ __ ] in
my house when I'm a cable that's a big
ass trailer is this all just liquor oh
[ __ ] yeah it looks like he lives in
Detroit where is he okay he's what you
call a bogan this is why we're all the
same this is why when everybody's like
oh you don't know Steve all Australia is
so different I'm like white trash is
Australia white rusted America white
rice boy tractors in China white rice
everywhere yeah it's true we always have
our burst of trash it's so funny because
like trash all over the world somehow
have the same taste - yeah they do and
the same distrust of the same certain
things right like like I need a house
that could be mobile at any point why
God these guys who think they're spies
are my favorite man okay and like meet
him even my brother my brother's wife
for the longest time wouldn't let him
get a cell phone because she didn't want
to she wanted to live off the grid I'm
like this [ __ ] in the Air Force
can't be more on the grid like they
literally own him
yeah and they know where he is at all
times yeah there's like people in like
the hood were they like guard their
[ __ ] ATM number don't look at that
[ __ ] you have no money nobody wants to
steal you if I stole your ID I kill
myself all right like [ __ ] man
and here he bought his property back in
2015 but he's being charged $50 a date
oh my god because of it a land like the
way he's not taking care of his land
like there's no sewage there's no
electricity like there's just he all
their sewage it's just on the front yard
you're stepping in it right now he looks
like a trash dump well not take a suit
every day he's like this is [ __ ] what
do you call the compost place oh my god
his whole trip I like how his satellite
is brand new and shiny hitting the fence
is all brand-new everything around it is
like a [ __ ] waste sewage plant yeah
his house looks like what a place would
look like after a tornado calms down
yeah yeah it was a lack of running water
not electricity he does that electricity
since he doesn't I was cable but
constant look on his face like look
while looking into the distance like he
lost everything in a hurricane relief
photo like compensate yeah come help all
the victims of the hurricane
yeah but he's refusing to pay all these
fines well he should have refused to
clean up like that's like it's like if
you don't want to pay then clean up your
filth yeah imagine what the inside of
that place smells like oh god yeah no I
don't want gee that's a hilarious dude
he's getting fine because he's creating
a mess not because right well it's
because he doesn't have any water or
sewage and he has that running water
apparently weird okay yeah because there
are key regulations that he's not
following
I get the sewage part because if he
doesn't have a septic tank or something
he's gonna [ __ ] all over and spread
[ __ ] e-coli or something yeah I was
looking at this photo right now and all
these jars I'm like oh maybe I think
it's moonshine I think it's moonshine
it's pee shine I don't know why he would
keep his own piss in his defense I
watched this hoarder episode were dis
guy he was [ __ ] and pissing into
like jars to save it now that's a
hoarder by
people like to say that their parents
are hoarders and [ __ ]
now that's a [ __ ] hoarder he couldn't
let go anything everything even his own
waste yep and when he get those you know
who's [ __ ] like coupons and
newspapers and [ __ ] in the mail he saves
all of that [ __ ] everything nothing goes
to waste nothing's thrown away my
cousin's
mother-in-law there's a hoarder to the
max like she saved like every like
[ __ ] strand of yarn and her shits
just packed through and he went all the
way over to like Idaho to help her clear
out her [ __ ] because I hey you got to
get rid of this stuff and she goes I
don't want to and he goes well why won't
you get rid here she's like he's like
fed up at this point he goes you need to
get rid of your [ __ ] right and she goes
well Jason during the Holocaust the
conversation it's like what the [ __ ] am
I supposed to say now my grandma went
through the Great Depression yeah we
were helping her clean out her freezer
and it was like going back in time to
the top of the freezer it was like okay
2005 and then as you dig into it's like
chicken nuggets from 1997 yeah and then
you go deeper we found a [ __ ] lobster
that's older than my 35 year old sister
oh my that's crazy
yeah at the very bottom yeah when you
found a dinosaur after that look if
there's a species of lobster that is now
extinct that's like it's like that
depression type of mentality and it
doesn't go away if she just like give
this whole spiel about the Holocaust he
just sort of sit there digging here he
goes okay well you could keep your yarn
[Music]